quand tu as un dealer qui te met un
couteau sous la gorge et tu lui dis bon
maintenant tu payes ça va ma se passer
bah tu le fais quoi moi je suis pas une
warrior à l'époque je fais pas de sport
de combat rien du tout donc j'obéis quoi
à cette loi du plus fort
Audrey Chenu bonsoir
alors Audrey
la prison est-elle l'école du crime et
de la récidive comme le dit la gauche ou
bien la prison est-elle la seule
punition susceptible de dissuader les
délinquants de recommencer comme le
soutien la droite vous êtes bien placé
pour en parler à l'adolescence alors que
vos profs voyaient intégrer HEC vous
écouliez sans kilos de cannabis par
semaine
et puis vous êtes tombé et là après la
prison vous êtes devenu institutrice
cette histoire vous l'a racontée dans un
livre intitulé girl fight publié au
prince de la cité et à 20h dans Salut
les Terriens
Audrey chénée rebonsoir vous êtes né le
2 octobre 1980 à Lagny-sur-Marne votre
père bosse à la poste et votre mère est
serveuse dans un Flunch il y a trois
autres enfants dans la famille en départ
c'est une jolie petite maison dans un
village au bord de mer à quelques
kilomètres de Caen et vous avez une
scolarité plutôt épanouie
jusqu'ici alors tout ça commence bien
hélas derrière ce tableau
idyllique la maladie gangrène toute la
famille d'abord depuis la naissance de
votre frère à votre mère est contaminée
par le virus de l'hépatite C votre frère
lui sombre dans la dépression votre sœur
est épileptique ce qui fait qu'on
s'intéresse beaucoup à elle et pas
beaucoup à vous et votre père est
maniaco-dépressif il est interné
d'ailleurs à l'hôpital de la
Pitié-Salpêtrière
c'est du lourd ouais je sais c'est dur
en plus votre mère veut pas qu'on en
parle c'est l'omerta
tellement longtemps voilà j'ai pris un
peu le contre-pied de sa politique à
elle qui était de garder les choses
cachées et voilà de souffrir en silence
quoi moi j'ai besoin d'exploser à un
moment et alors malgré ces problèmes de
santé vos parents trouvent du boulot à
France Télécom et votre père ça va pas
bien il est placardisé la plupart du
temps toujours en arrêt maladie et votre
mère se retrouve en train de batailler
entre son boulot de secrétaire ses
enfants son mari parce qu'il fait qu'à
l'âge de 7 ans vous tenez vous Audrey la
maison toute seule comme j'étais la
fille aînée et que les garçons ne font
rien à la maison je me suis retrouvé
avec tout ça sur le dos à cet âge
précoce mais là justement en CM2 vous
commencez à en avoir marre d'être la
petite fille modèle vous devenez
insolente avec l'instit
et vous commencez à commettre vos
premiers larcins
c'est qu'il y a des choses qui sont
superflus nous on est dans un milieu
assez
non mais moi je vois bien autour de moi
que tous les élèves ils affichent des
marques et que si tu en as pas bah tu es
le vilain petit canard là donc ça fait
que je vais voler des trucs pour
améliorer l'ordinaire on va dire alors
la maison la situation se dégrade les
crises d'épilepsie de votre sœur sont
absolument terribles vos parents font
chambre à part et le pire c'est toujours
cette omerta imposé par par votre mère
pour fuir tout ça vous commencez à fumer
des cigarettes à prendre des cuites dès
la 4e mais alors ce qui est
extraordinaire avec vous c'est que vos
bulletins scolaires sont toujours
excellents
ouais bah disons que j'ai eu besoin en
tant que préado de faire comme les
autres quoi donc voilà première
cigarettes première relâche de pelle qui
était pathétique d'ailleurs
vraiment parce qu'il avait un appareil
et tout
voilà et après voilà tu gardes ça m'a
rien apporté j'arrête assez vite en
arrivant au lycée Dumont d'Urville à
Caen vous découvrez le cannabis alors là
évidemment vous dites je planais à 15000
le verrou des interdits venait de sauter
définitivement
ça désigne donc ça permet de libérer
ouais des pulsions des envies des désirs
et à la suite c'est l'engrenage
évidemment vous fumez de plus en plus
vous commencez à deviler pour payer
votre consommation alors au début c'est
des œufs doux c'est à dire c'est 12 g de
ensuite c'est des 25 et puis comme le
fournisseur avec qui vous travaillez ne
peut plus répondre à la demande vous
négociez directement avec l'échelon
supérieur et vous passez à la demi
savonnette c'est à dire 250 g là ça
devient quand même
à l'époque et voilà j'ai commencé à
Diler de plus en plus et homme défoncer
aussi parce que vous fumez le matin
avant d'aller au lycée ou fumer à la
récré ou fumer pendant les changements
de cours et des fois pendant le cours
vous demandez d'aller aux toilettes pour
aller prendre une douille dans les
chiottes quoi j'avoue ça c'est la
dépendance c'est pas quelque chose dont
je suis fière mais comme tout le monde
voilà quand on commence un truc qui vous
fait du bien c'est difficile de doser
d'arrêter surtout à cette époque de
l'adolescence font les ou voilà on se
laisse un peu alors votre business
fonctionne bien à 17 ans vous avez votre
chambre en ville une clientèle fidèle et
vous commencez à gagner pas mal de
pognon et un jour vous faites casser une
porte défoncée ou faite piquer votre
argent et votre chien et c'est pour vous
refaire parce que vous avez plus rien
que vous transformez votre petit
commerce en plaques tournante régionale
d'un trafic international là vous vendez
jusqu'à 100 kg par semaine à ce
moment-là ouais effectivement là c'était
moins drôle là c'est pas moi qui ai
décidé de vendre tous ces kilos quoi
c'est juste quand un dealer qui te met
un couteau sous la gorge et tu dis bon
maintenant tu payes ou ça va ma se
passer bah tu le fais quoi moi je suis
pas une warrior à l'époque je fais pas
de sport de combat rien du tout donc
j'obéis quoi à cette loi du plus fort
alors le plus fort c'est que vous
décrochez votre bac avec une
recommandation des profs pour s'inscrire
à hippocaille ou en prépa HEC
parallèlement au 100 kg de shit par
semaine
ensuite vous inscrivez à la faculté de
sociologie cela vous permet de sauver
les apparences en continuant votre
business à l'époque vous avez mis de
côté 500 000 francs votre objectif c'est
d'en mettre un million de francs de côté
ça fait quand même 150 000 euros c'est
beaucoup d'argent l'idée d'avoir un
pactole suffisant pour pas travailler
pendant quelques années et pouvoir être
libre de bouger de lutter là où il y
avait besoin et voilà de faire ce que
j'avais envie de faire ce que mon coeur
me dicté et parce que la société me
dicter mais un matin à l'heure du
laitier vous êtes réveillés par des
coups de bélier contre votre porte c'est
la police vous avez été balancé par un
petit intermédiaire et vous vous
retrouvez à la prison pour femme de
Versailles et là vous risquez 10 ans
quand même
ouais donc première garde à vue j'ai 18
ans et voilà je me retrouve quatre jours
d'affilée parce que les stups ça rigole
pas c'est 96 heures voilà sans manger
avec un chantage pour aller aux
toilettes qui vous rend dingue dans une
cellule qui pue la merde et la pièce etc
le sang enfin là vous découvrez
l'univers carcéral alors l'amitié à la
vie à la mort avec votre copine Marcel
la solidarité entre les détenus mais
aussi la violence sexuelle vous entendez
la nuit des choses épouvantables les
suicides aussi même la fille du
directeur de la prison s'est suicidé
et franchement il y a de aussi de ça
c'est clair parce que vu ce qu'elles
font au quotidien enfin voilà moi j'ai
vu beaucoup de mesquinerie de bassesse
d'humiliation d'injustice gratuite au
fond qui servent à rien qui font que du
mal aux personnes incarcérées
effectivement les filles tiennent avec
du lexomil du xanax du Subutex pour les
tocs et vous vous continuez à fumer du
shit parce qu'en fait il y a un système
très simple c'est des boulettes dans des
préservatifs que les gens qui arrivent
au parloir ont dans la bouche ils le fil
à la fille qui le met dans le vagin et
ensuite ça continue ça rentre dans la
cellule comme ça
ouais bah dehors comme dedans la bonne
matière faut faire tourner quoi c'est
l'idée donc voilà quand on en a un
partage vous avez besoin aussi de
nourriture intellectuelle vous inscrivez
en socio à l'université de Caen je me
suis renseignée rapidement j'ai vu que
c'était possible de suivre des études
par correspondance et je me suis dit je
fais ça direct parce que je sais pas si
je suis là pendant 10 ans un an deux ans
voilà vraiment à l'époque je savais pas
jouer dans ce temps là quelque chose
pour moi et pour les autres quoi alors
là après 8 mois de détention vous vous
êtes radicalisés vous devenez une
meneuse vous hurlez dès qu'il y a une
décision arbitraire d'une matonne par
exemple à un moment il y a des steaks
hachés qui sont servis au réfectoire qui
tombent par terre on les donne à manger
aux détenus là vous péter un câble je
suis vraiment en sujet je comprends pas
ce système ça dépasse mon entendement
quoi pourquoi faire du mal gratuitement
quoi vous vous retrouvez au mitard
ensuite à Fresnes et la Fresnes quand
vous arrivez vous vous dites Versailles
à côté c'est le monde des bisounours là
c'était du dressage pur et simple en
vrai où on m'a dit là il y a une ligne
jaune dans la coursive le couloir tu
dois marcher le long de la ligne jaune
tu dois pas mettre les mains dans tes
poches donc forcément je mettais tout le
temps les mains dans les poches moi
c'est une façon de se tenir et tout
voilà et que des trucs comme ça interdit
de se parler interdit de donner un
sachet de thé à une détenue qui a rien à
bouffer à boire de toute la semaine là
donc moi des mesures comme ça ouais
forcément je fonde quoi voilà mais à
votre grande surprise vous êtes libéré
au bout d'une semaine vous êtes libre
jusqu'à votre procès mais à peine dehors
malgré le contrôle judiciaire vous
récidivez après une tentative de boulot
au McDo de Versailles vous reprenez le
business je sors du jour au avec mon sac
avec mon numéro d'écoute devant la porte
de la tôle et je fais quoi donc bon
heureusement il y a une détenue encore
une fois la solidarité entre détenus qui
m'a hébergé et tout ça parallèle bien
sûr j'avais repris un peu de business le
minimum pour survivre parce que quand tu
sors sans logement et sans un rond tu
fais quoi donc j'ai repris mes habitudes
voilà et puis le jour du procès arrive
là vous prenez un an de prison mais
grâce à la préventive que vous avez
effectuée et aux remises de peine vous
ressortez libre 15 jours plus tard les
flics découvrent chez vous du shit de la
coke des extras et du liquide retour à
la case prison freine et là vous décidez
de vous ressaisir vous mettez au sport
la muscu et surtout vous inscrivez au
cycle conférences débats philosophiques
qui ont lieu une fois par mois et ça ça
vous sauve parce que je passais mon
temps à lire à écrire et donc j'ai
rencontré un prof qui s'appelle François
qui fait partie de la section des
étudiants empêché qui a un service
depuis Foucault depuis 1974 et ça c'est
des gens qui sont battus pour que les
prisonniers et des droits et accès aux
études universitaires et je les remercie
aujourd'hui parce que sinon je serais
encore au McDo quoi ou en tôle je sais
pas mais un jour il vous prend comme ça
dans ses bras et vous dites c'est la
première fois qu'on me traite pas comme
un déchet c'est nouveau pour moi que je
suis là-bas depuis des mois où je me
prends que des coups des sales remarque
ou je me retrouve au cachot mon corps il
est malmené on va le faire quoi et donc
oui de d'être voilà prise dans les bras
de quelqu'un juste simplement
ça fait du bien alors après 12 mois de
détention vous sortez de Fresnes cette
fois votre désir de réinsertion est
solide vous commencez à avoir envie
d'enseigner et puis Audrey à ce
moment-là vous êtes amoureuse vous avez
rencontré une Française d'origine
guyanaise qui a été arrêtée à l'aéroport
avec 3 kilos de cannabis en prison avec
Kaila on s'est super bien entendu c'est
une rencontre qui a changé beaucoup de
choses dans ma vie et depuis j'aime les
femmes et et là vous passez le concours
d'un site vous êtes reçu haut la main
avec 20 sur 20 et aujourd'hui vous êtes
un site à Bobigny
en effet j'adore mon métier ça fait les
parents d'élèves d'où venait j'ai pas eu
de retour si ce n'est de la part des
élèves qui eux regardent la télé sans
doute avec leurs parents mais moi je les
respecte j'apprends des choses à leurs
enfants je les aime et je les accompagne
dans leur vie et je les aide à grandir
et c'est tout ce que demandent les
parents à une instit je crois alors vous
dites j'ai enfin l'impression d'avoir
réussi ma vie j'ai une existence libre
ou l'argent est secondaire ou la
monotonie n'a pas cours
effectivement quand on choisit le
professeur des écoles c'est pas pour
l'argent qu'on le fait parce qu'on est
mal payé et que c'est un métier où il y
a d'ailleurs une crise de l'avocation en
ce moment si on a qu'on vit pour moi ça
reste le plus beau métier du monde donc
on peut dire que la prison qui est
souvent racontée comme l'école du crime
pour vous ça a eu une influence
vertueuse c'est plutôt les rencontres
les livres que j'ai eu dans les mains à
ces moments-là et ce que j'y ai fait
mais elle aurait pu très bien me casser
comme la plupart des gens dans ce
système carcéral ce qui vous a sauvé
c'est vous c'est votre curiosité voilà
et avec les autres
merci de votre témoignage et pour être
sûr de ne rien rater de innarditude
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu